[موسيقى]
نحو العاصمه البريطانيه لندن كانت الوجهه
هذه المره للقاء شخص يراه البعض دائما
مسالمه وصديقه للبيئه لكن على الضفه
الاخرى له اخرون ذلك الشرسه الملتزم
بقناعات يقاتل في سبيلها الحكومه
والتيارات
[موسيقى]
بالشخص الصادق
هو انسان
لخدمه حقوق الانسان والعداله الاجتماعيه
وحيدا اواجه روبيات حاولت تصويره بانه لا
يصلح للقياده في بريطانيا بتهمه معاده
الساميه الا انه بقي الصوت المناصره
لفلسطين
[موسيقى]
في الوقوف مع الجاليه المسلمه ليس فقط في
المنطقه هنا في منطقه ازنكتون ولكن
المسلمين بشكل عام في في كل انحاء
بريطانيا اخيرا يجب ان اذكر وقوفه مع
فلسطين ومع حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني في
الدفاع عن ارضه ضد المحتلين
اجمل المعارك السياسيه بل اذهل العالم
بعناده وتمرده وثباته على مبادئ استمد
منها قوه جعلته الرجل الاكثر شعبيه بين
اقراره في حزب العمال رغم محاولات الاطاحه
به
اعضاء البرلمان من حزب العمال معارضته
وتقويض نفوده لقد جعل من حزب العمال اكبر
حركه في غرب اوروبا وعامل على ان يكون
لدينا بنيه سياسيه قادره على معالجه
القضايا الرئيسيه في البلاد ومن عده اوجه
يعد القائد الاساسيه للحركه ككل وما زال
من هذا الباب يلهم الناس ويحركهم وسيكون
له دور فاعل لفتره طويله في المستقبل
هو اليسرى المتمرد الذي مشى في الطريق
الملغم حتى وصل الى القمه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى الجذور العميقه في عائله
كوربن نجد ان والديك تعرف على بعضهما
البعض في مناسبه سياسيه ياسريه جمعتهما
السياسه قبل
الحكملات حقوق الانسان
تشرب السياسه من هذه النشئه
على ان يتعلم الناس بانفسهم
كانت ترى ان افضل ما في منظومه التعليميه
هي انك تستطيعين ان تتعلمي بنفسك
فاعطتني كتبا وتركت لي عند وفاتها الكثير
منها وهي في منزلي كان حريصين على ان
يستكشف الناس الافكار ولم يلقنانا الافكار
السياسيه ابدا الرجاء
الاقتصادي للعائله كان فوق المتوسط واعتاد
الناس ربما هنا في بريطانيا ان يترجم
الفلاحين او الطبقه الكادحه الى اليسار
هناك قد يسال البعض لماذا اتجهت العائله
هذا الاتجاه
تماما
عمل بجده طوال حياتهما ولم يفكر بتوريث
الثراء لاحد كان ملتزمين في فيهما واعتنى
بناء جميعنا جيدا
وانشانا نشاه حسنه
المدرسه مثلا في الاعداديه كان ااا الاهلي
يدفعون قرابه 3500 باوند الى جنيه
استرليني او 4,500 جنيه وهو مبلغ يعني
عالي جدا في ذلك الزمان لماذا اختارت اصلا
الاسره ان ترسل الى مدرسه مدفوعه الثمن
وكان هناك خيار وهو التعليم المجاني
في الابتدائيه وليس في الاعداديه كنت في
السابعه او الثامنه
وعندما انتقلت الى الثانويه
للطلاب وانا لا اؤيد هذا النظاميه
8 لماذا اتخذ ذلك القرار فقد حيرني الامر
ولم اجد له اجابه
منذ الطفوله يعني اثار استغرابي بانك في
المرحله الدراسيه كنت حتى ترفض الانضمام
للكشافه لانها تعكس السلطه لماذا كل هذا
التمرد على السلطه منذ الطفوله
عندما كبرت قليلا
بالكشافه وانما بالتدريب العسكري وهو تابع
للجيش وقد رفضته الالتحاق به بسبب معارضه
لحرب فيتنام وقلت لا شك ان هناك طريقه
افضل لاداره الامور المدرسه ضغطت علي
كثيره وقالوا عليك الالتحاق بالتدريب انت
الوحيد في الحقيقه كنا اثنين يقولون انت
الوحيد
قبل ان اترك المدرسه قال
انت لن تفلح ابدا في حياتك
والناشط والمثقف والشخص كثير الاطلاع
لم يتغير الجامعه لماذا لم تكمل الدراسه
الجامعيه
فتركت بعد سته اسابيع ان كان الفصل
الدراسي سخيفا فلم ابقى هناك
في غرفه صغيره
قرات تاريخ الهندسه
هل انت نادم على عدم المدير قدما ااه في
تلقي همم التعليم الجامعي
فرصه النقاشات لكن لست نادما تماما
وفي السفر
والتحدث الى الناس
يثبوجر ميكر في الحديث لكنه لا يخرج عن
كونه نسيج نفسه
في عمر السادس عشر انضمت الى حزب العمال
لماذا العمال تحديدا
بالانتخابات العامه في عام 64 عندما كنت
في الخامسه عشر كنت اقرا الصحف كل احد حول
الحمله الانتخابيه وكانت لدينا حكومه
محافظين لفتره طويله ومتحمسه وكان شعار
حزب العمال جميلا يقول هيا مع العمال مع
رفع الابهاء انضمت الى حزب العمال لاني
رايتها الوسيله الوحيده التي يمكن ان تحدث
تغيير اجتماعيا
كيف تصف هذه التجربه
راكان ابن جويل
مباشر
اكتبه
وبسبب نشاط السياسي في المنطقه وقد راى ان
هذه ليست مواضيعتنا صحيفه محليه لكننا في
النهايه افترقنا بطريقه ودينيه
وصف كتاباتك بالسيئه
اظن من غير المنصف قول ذلك لاظنه قال ان
كتاباتي سيئه بل قال انه لا يتفق مع ما
اكتب وهذاني امران مختلفهان
1969 و1970 اقمت في جامايكا وعملتها
كمدرسه الجغرافيا كيف لشخص لم يتخرج من
الجامعه ان يعمل مدرس و يدرس الطلاب
ولماذا ماده الجغرافيا تحديدا
في المعلمين في ذلك الوقت وكان يحاولون
توسيع رقعه التعليم الثانوي ورفع سويه
المدارس ويحاولون تطوير التعليم الاساسي
وطلبوا من المتطوعين المجيئه من بلدان
اخرى وذهبت عن طريق منظمه تدعى الخدمه
التطوعيه الخارجيه وكنت اعلم اني غير مؤهل
جامعيه ولكني اكملت التعليمه الثانويه
وطبعا كنت اتلقى النصائح من المعلمين
الاخرين في المدرسه هذه جيده في العمل كلا
ليست جيدا لكن شعرت اني امام تحدي واني
سابذل ما بوسعي لمساعدتها هؤلاء الشبان في
دراسه الجغرافيا حسنا لم يكن وضعا جيدا
انا اريد ان يكون المعلمون مدربين ومؤهلين
باقصى احدكم وفعلتما بوسعي في ذلك الوقت
وربما تعلمت اكثر مما تعلمت
ربما
وارى ان كافه الشباب يجب ان تتاح لهم
الفرصه للالتحاق بالتعليم الاساسي
تماما وحتى في بريطانيا هناك معلمون غير
مؤهلين يمارسون التعليم حتى الان واظن ان
هذا امر سيء جدا
كانت اوقات كانت قويه وقاسيه وعنيده وكانت
لها اجندها لتدمير الاتحاد التجاريه
وتدمير اليسار وتدمير المشاعر المجتمعيه
في بريطانيا
في البرلمان واتحاد الاقليات الاخرى
بالعدو من الداخل
الجنونيه من مثل كل من تعدى الخامسه
والعشرين ومازال يركب الحافله هو فاشل
كوشي الجزء
الاول
الشخصيه وبيع الممتلكات العامه وممتلكات
الدوله وهذا ما فعلته بالجمله
[موسيقى]
على حساب المجتمع شيفاي
الذي خلفته من اللؤم واللامبالاه والقسوه
في المواجهه
وان يكون تقدمك على حساب الاخرين مازال
قائما
[موسيقى]
كان واختا سيئا لبريطانيا وسيئ لك بطبيعه
الحال وربما علاقات السيئه في حياتك هي
كثيرا فمع بدايه المسار السياسي وجهت لك
تهم بدعم الارهاب لعلاقه تربطك بجماعه
كانت تدعى رد اكشن مرتبطه بالجيش
الايرلنديين الايرلندي
1987 قط انتخابات حقيقيه للمره الاولى
حينها قالت صحيفه سندس لا تنتقب هذا الرجل
انه رجل شرير مروع فارتفعت غالبيته من
4000 الى عشره الاف
[تصفيق]
والالفيه الثانيه مرحله يحسب لك فيها بانك
ضعفت عدد المنتسبين الى حزب العمال فهل
كان ذلك بدافع الوصول الى الزعامه
الحزب لكن اذا استعرضت مسيره حياتي اجد من
خرجت في الكثير من نشاطات الميدانيه في
حملات مناهضه العنصريه وحملات اتحاد
التجاره وحملات العداله وعلى وجه الخصوص
في حملات السلم ومناهضه الحروب 2015
10 ارتفع حجم العضويه الى 600 الف عضو
اصبحت لدينا قاعده ضخمه من الناشطين
والمؤيدين
واجهنا هجوما كبيرا من الاعلام
لكننا حققنا قاعده المجتمعيه وحتى الان
رغم اني لم اعد زعيم الحزب ما زلت نشطا
كما انا هناك حركه هائله من قبل الناس
المصممين السياسيين على عدم التعايش مع
مجتمع لا مبال عنصري منقسم ثقيل وانا افخر
بهذه الانجازات
[موسيقى]
في الثاني عشر من سبتمبر من العام 2015 في
زكور بمبي برئاسه حزب العمال البريطاني
بنسبه قاربه 60% ما شكل الانتصارا هو
الاكبر متربعا على عرش حزبن يعد من اكبر
احزاب المعارضه البريطانيه هل تفاجات
بوصلك الى زعامه حزب العمال كما تفاجئ
العالم ام ان الامر كان مخطط له او متوقع
كبيرا وراء الامر
الحقيقه المحزنه انها كانت تراكما من
الظروف المعقده المثيره وساوضح باختصار في
الانتخابات العامه 2015 خسر حزبنا العمال
كانت هناك امور جيده في البيان لكن لم
نقطع عليه الطريق حيث لم نقترح تغيرا
اقتصاديا حقيقيا وخسرنا الانتخابات بعدها
مباشره كانت هناك نقاشات بين زملاء اليسار
في البرلمان حول هل نجرب انتخابا على
زعامه الحزب حيث قرر ميلي باند التنحي كنت
مع راي القائل ان علينا ان نقيم نوعا من
التحدي لنظهر وجودنا واننا لنبحث فقط عن
بديل بينما شكك اخرون في الخطوه وبدات
حملات شعبيه لمحاوله دفع برلماني حزب
العمال لاتخاذ قرار بشان خوض التحدي
واستمرت هذه النقاشات وقد كانت ممله وكانت
الحمله الشعبيه الوحيده التي حصد ذلك
الرقم
[موسيقى]
مع بعض الاصدقاء وخرج ابني وكان هناك
يراقب ما يحدث فقال
نحن في المرشحين ومن هناك بدانا وفزنا من
الجوله الاولى
حزب العمال سعيت الى احداث تغييرات هيكليه
في توجهات الحزب هل كنت تحاول فرض افكارك
في تلك المرحله ام ان حزب العمال كان
بحاجه فعلا الى تلك التغيرات
التي اردنا ان نحدثها ولن يكون
مستعدليه من اعضاء اتحادات التجاره واعضاء
الحزب وبعض المنظمات التابعه
ذات العمر الطويل فان الرسميات
والبيمقراطيه تدافع عنها وقد ارادوا ان
اتجنب امرين
[موسيقى]
حيث المجتمعات هي التي تنظم الحملات وهي
التي تحد الاهداف بين الانتخابات
وارادوا الا اقلل من قوه حزب العمال
البرلمانيه في تقرير السياسات وفي تحديد
الاتجاه العام للحزب كان هذا تحديا منذ
البدايه وكان اول ما فعلته عندما تخبت هو
الترحيب باللاجئين لاني اردت ان اوضح اني
ارحب باللاجئين وادعمهم
وكانت اشاره ايضا لتعرف الحركه اننا سنحدث
فارغاظه
ومن ثم كانت هناك بعض الفعاليات المختلفه
ولكن التحرك كان سريعا وقد ان تخبت في
الثانيه عشر من ايلول لذا كان علي الاجابه
على اسئله رئيس الوزراء بعد اربعه او خمسه
ايام واتذكر انني توجهت الى قاعه مجلس
العمره وكانت مقتضه تماما كافه المقاعد
خلفي كانت ملاى والتي امامي مقاعد الحكومه
ومقاعد منصه جلد بنظري وقلت
كان لي 12 صديقا كانوا اصدقائي المقربين
من برلماني حزب العمال وبعض الاصدقاء فيلم
منصه
ثم ادركت ان الامر سيكون صعبا فقد كانت
الحكومه منعقده لمهاجمته
[موسيقى]
منذ اليوم الاول وجهت العديد من الازمات
المتراكمه والمركبه انصحها التعبير كيف
تعاملت مع هذا الكم الكبير من الدسائس ضدك
[موسيقى]
ليس من السهل التعامل مع الع التي
واجهناها وقد توقعت ان يكون الامر صعبا
لكنه كان اسوا ب 10 مرات مما توقعت
وتلقيت انتقادا مباشره من كافه الصحف وكل
شيء لمسته وكل شخص تحدث اليه تعرض لكل
كبير من التحرير والانتقاد كان الامر
صعباوت
عدد منهم لم يريد ان يخدم في فريق واخرون
ارادوا لكن بشروط رفضتها
كيف تتعاملين مع ذلك
لا يجدينا
التواصل معهم وهذا امر صعب
بدايه سهله
ويذان
سياسات الحزب وتطويرها
[موسيقى]
العمال بنسبه 40% وهي اكبر نسبه يحصدها
عام 1997 البعض عزاء
النصر بضعف اداء ااه وارتباع تيريزا معي
وليس لقوه حملتك الانتخابيه التي قال
البعض بانها افتقدت الاجنده او
الاستراتيجيه كيف ترد على هذا الوصف ليه
الحمله الانتخابيه التي عندك
24 بالمئهن
[موسيقى]
سنتين
في يوم اعلان الانتخابات حول من الذي
ستفعله الان هل ستستسلم ام ستتنحل فقلت
اننا سنخرج ونوصل الرساله
[موسيقى]
بتوظيف اناس لم يسجلوا للانتخاب
فيما يخص العداله الاقتصاديه على ارض
الواقعه والخدمات الصحيه والاسكان كل هذه
القضايا كنا نقول لنتجاهل الهستيريا
ونستثمر في المستقبل
لماذا
وجهت الاله الاعلاميه ضد جيمي كوبين بعد
هذه الفتره تحديدا
بشان اعاده تشكيل الاعلام
لذا وجهنا بحمله
كمثال على مدى قوتها في يوم الانتخابات
عام 2017
صفحه لمهاجمته وفي كل صفحه قصه مختلفه من
الدراجه
الثقافه السياسيه لهذا البلد والاهم
التغيير في السياسه الخارجيه لهذا
البلدها اتهامك بمعاداه الساميه
ملعونه
اخرى في المانيا
كانت هناك اتهامات عن صدور تعليقات
اسلاميه من اناس داخل الحزب عن اعضاء
اليهود في الحزب لقد صدمني هذا الامر
للتعامل مع هذا الامر وكل حاله ينبغي
التحقيق بها فاذا لم يجد شيئا يغلقونها
واذا كان في الامر
فعليك ان تتخذي رد فعل تاديبا
اسسنا لهذه العمليه لكن الانتقادات تواصلت
وارى بصراحه انها لم تكن عادله ابدا
[موسيقى]
الى تصحيح هذه الصوره من خلال ربما التوجه
بشكل مباشر الى الاعلام البريطانيين لماذا
لا يزال الحديث قائم بانك تهاجم وتعادي
السميع حسنا
[موسيقى]
انها منظمات يهوديه من التيار السائد
كلجنه
اخرى داعمه
مناسبه وكذلك اتخذنا اجراءات ضد القضايا
التمييز المدفوع من الاسلام فوبيا
عدد قضايا الاتهامات بالسلوك المعادل
الساميه اقل بكثير من واحد بالمئه من
اعضاء الحزب ولكني قلت بوضوح
معدات الساميه خطا فادح تحت ايضا
وقلت بان موقفه يناقد موقف حكومه المملكه
المتحده ما هو موقف بريطانيا تحديدا برايك
من صفقه
واسعه من الضفه
على ما مع اي جهه فلسطينيه بل رتب للامر
مع اليمين في اسرائيل وقد عرضت هذا بقوه
لاني اعتقد ان الشعب الفلسطيني من حقه
تقرير مصيره بنفسه
الغربيه وحصار غزه وازاله المستوطنات في
الضفه الغربيه فما تم عرضه في الواقع هو
شبكه من مناطق الحكم الذاتي على مدى الضفه
الغربيه اذا رايت ان الحكومه البريطانيه
كان يجب يمكن ان يكون موقفها اقوى
فموقفها الرسمي يرفض استمرار سياسه بناء
المستوطنات ويؤيده عمليه سلام على اساس حل
الدولتين عيد
[موسيقى]
الحكومه البريطانيه تبيع السلاح لاسرائيل
وتستورده ايضا
وقد سالت مؤخرا في البرلمان
يستخدم السلاح البريطاني في القصف الاخير
على غزه ولم اسمحوا لي هذه الضمانه
وهكذا كان موقفي اننا كحكومه يجب ان نعترف
بدوله فلسطين وبلا شروط وان نوقف تزويد
اسرائيل بالسلاح وانرفض استيراد بضائع
المستوطنات في بلدنا وان نفعل ما بوسعنا
لتحقيق العداله للشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
ين
الجزء الاول
في ذلك الوقت
حكومه الحرب عام
1917 امم
بوينيات
نشطت حركه الهجره من قبل اليهود الى ما
صار يعرف باسرائيل
كان هناك اعتراف بدوله اسرائيل وعاش الشعب
الفلسطيني النكبه وهجر مئات الالاف
يعيشون
في بريطانيا التاريخ
شعب الفلسطيني
سهام كوربين لم تتجه نحو بريطانيا فحسب بل
سدد رميه ايضا نحو اوروبا والى اي مكان
تدور فيه الصراعات السياسيه والحروب
[تصفيق]
يا لهوي
[موسيقى]
القضيه الفلسطينيه والحرب على غزه ملف لم
يغب عن نشاطاته وان كان الاكثر حساسيه في
مجتمع تنقسم فيه الاراء حول قضيه جوهريه
في بريطانيا تمضي من خلالها التعاطف
الكامل مع الفلسطينيين والقضيه الفلسطينيه
من ثم قمت بالتغريد وقلت بان اسرائيل
تتحمل مسؤوليه التصعيد وان بيدها الحل ما
هو هذا الحل برايك او من وجهه نظرك اوكي
لكن
باسرائيل تملك السلاح والقوه وهنا ساسالك
سؤال جومي كوربن هل تؤمن بان للشعوب
بالدفاع عن نفسها
في الاساس نعم لديهم الحق لكني لا اريد ان
اكون في ذلك الموقف لا اريد ان يطلق الناس
النار على بعضهم البعض فذلك ليس حلا على
المدى البعيد هذا مؤداه مزيد من القتلى
ومزيد من العنف
المساله يجب ان تحل سياسيا
واسرائيل حصلت على موافقه الولايات
المتحده على كل ما فعله
من معظم الدول اوروبا خاصه
الغربيه
[موسيقى]
وهذه جريمه
مهاجمه الاهداف المدنيه هي جريمه حرب
وهذا يحدث خللا في ميزان الموقف باكمله
ولهذا اؤيد بشده حق الفلسطينيين في الوجود
والبقاء
باكمله
على غزه اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
سابقا
المثال
في البرلمان البريطاني لكن سرعان ما سحبت
هذه الدعوه لماذا ما الذي سوف تغير طيب
حماس او كانوا يمثلونها ومنظمات اخرى
تناقش هذه الامور مع حماس على كل حال طوال
الوقت وقد حضرت اجتماعات كهذه قبل زمن
بعيد
ميؤوس
صلاح
ولماذا كان في بريطانيا
البريطاني ما اريد ان اقوله هو ان اي سلام
على المدى البعيد يجب ان يشمل كافه
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وكافه المكونات
من القضيه الفلسطينيه من العراق من
باكستان وغيرها افقدت كبعض المكتسبات
السياسيه
العمال فقلت ان احدى المشاكل ان حزب
العمال لا يتحدث بما يكفي عن ايرل ويجب ان
تكون هناك عمليه سلام في ايرلندا وفي
النهايه هذا ما حدث فهل هذا يعني ان
خياراتك السياسيه محدوده ربما لكن ليس هذا
ما خط غمار السياسه من اجله وجهه نظر هي
انني اذ ارى الظلمه ولا مساواه والفقر حول
العالم فان علي ان استعمل موقعي لفعل ما
استطيع بشانها
في تويتر
كانت مشكله العراق كانت مشكله
دبور
على حجه كاذبه حول مزاعم عن تهديد العراق
لبقيه العالم
على العراق
فبريطانيا كانت تبيع سلاحا لصدام حسين
يستخدم في القمع داخليا وكنت وحيدا في هذا
الموقع
حاول الزملاء في البرلمان اسكاتي لان في
عدم بيع السلاح في معرض اسلحه بغداد
تقويضا لمصالح بريطانيا
وحقوق الانسان وهل ارى انه يجب ان تقوم
حرب ضد ايران بالتاكيد الى هل اعتقد انه
يجب ان تكون هناك محادثات حول قضايا حقوق
الانسان مع ايران نعم وهل يجب ان يكون
اتفاق النووي مع ايران نعم بالتاكيد اذا
ايتها الاتفاق النوويه مع ايران وقد زرت
ايران
تشجيعي على الاتفاق في الماضي
نحقق السلام عندما نعترف بالشعوب
ونحترم ما يحاولون تحقيقه
اخرى لافته لزعيم حزب العمال البريطاني
كريستال مر في تغريده قائلا ان سلفه وهو
انت لن يشغل بعد اليوم وقعده البرلماني
بصفته نائما عن الحزب هنا لدي سؤال هل
تعتقد ان حياتك السياسيه قد انتهت خاصه مع
كل هذه المواقف التي تحدثنا عنها من بعض
القضايا الحساسه بالنسبه للمجتمع والسياسه
عن بريطانيا
الوقت وانا ساواصل التحدث عن الاشياء التي
اراها مهمه وتتعلق بالعداله وانا افخر
باني قلت حزب العمال ل خمس سنوات
وافخر بالتغيير الذي احدثناه في سياسه
الحزب والتحسينات والديمقراطيه التي تحققت
حزب العمال وقد علقت عضويه لوقت قصيره
العمال البرلماني والعديد من الناس
يصارعون لاجل ممن يعتقدون انه يجب اعاده
الى تجمع الحزب البرلماني
وعضو في البرلمان ولكن لا اتسمع عضو
برلمان عماليا وارى بصراحه ان هذا ينطوي
على اهانه كبيره فقد مثلت المجتمع هنا
ثمانيه وثلاثين عاما وانضمنت لحزب العمال
قبل 55 عاما اما قناعه الاشتراكيه فلم
تتغير واصرار على حقوق الانسان والسلام
والعداله لم يتغير واذا ما كان هناك جدله
بهذا الشان فليكن
[موسيقى]
لماذا رفضت الدعوه الرسميه لتناول العشاء
مع الرئيس الامريكي عندما كان في زياره
الى بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
قال انه غير مستعد للقيام بتقاليد زياره
الرسميه اي ان يخطب الرئيس الزائر في مجلس
زي العموم لبريطانيا
اينشتاين
ان هذا جاء بترتيب من الحكومه البريطانيه
نعم تحدثت عنه خلال تظاهره كبيره لكنني
قلت خلال حديث انني اسعد جدا بلقاء زائرين
الولايات المتحده
بهذا الشكل قد يسال سائل لماذا
زيارته لبريطانيا لمهاجمه زعيم المعارضه
اه
الشباب خاصه الشباب العربي وانت مهتم به
بشكل كبير وهو الذي يعاني همم من الاحباط
احيانا ودائما نقول السيد بالعالم العربي
نقول ما اضيق العيش لولا فسحه الامل
هناك
وحماسهم
وقدرتهم على محاوله تغيير الامور
السنه
في العالم
كسر كور بين المعارض العادات والتقاليد
الرسميه فهو من رفض تقبيل يد الملكه
اليزابيث والانحناء لها لكنه لم يتردد
يوما في الانحناء لمن ملكت قلبه
اكثر من 50 عام في السياسه كنت فيها رجل
متمرد لنقول رفضت القيود لكن ماذا عن
حياتك الشخصيه هل كنت ايضا فيها متمرد
واحاول ان اذهب الى معظم الاماكن التي اود
الذهاب اليها لا
اهدىتك
[موسيقى]
للبحث عن نفسك لتكون مسموعا مع ثلاثه
اولاد اكبر منه
فلوس
منحني والداي الحريه
وملؤها الحب وانا فخور بهم جميعا ونحن
نتحدث يوميا تقريبا وحريتهم في البيت
كامله انها علاقه رائعه
خاصه خلال السنوات الخمس الماضيه حيث كانت
الحياه قاسيه عليها
صعبه هل هذا ما يبرر انك تزوجت ثلاث مرات
ربما نعم ربما هذا هو السبب
زوجه الاولى ربما ضاقت بذرعه همم
ربما لم نفكر بما نريده في الحياه
وانفصلنا بعد اربع سنوات
جيده معا لكن العلاقه لم تدور
ثلاثه اطفال كنا شخصين مختلفين احدنا عن
الاخر طريقتنا مختلفه وسلوكنا مختلف تجاه
الحياه همم همم ووصلنا الى نهايه الطريق
لكنها والده ابنائي كانت علاقتنا جيده
تقوم بتصوير اغطيه الصرف الصحي في الشارع
وتوثق تاريخها من اين جاءت هذه الهوايه
غريبه
عن الاثار الرومانيه
في الشارع وهكذا الامر فعندما تنظرين الى
اغطيه المصارف
فستعرفين تاريخ ظهور انظمه الصرف الصحي
البلديه وطريقه دخول كهرباء البلديه
وطريقه دخول نظام ترامب
صحيا ما زالت موجوده منذ اكثر من 100 عام
وانا التقط صوره لهذه الاشياء واستخدمها
كنوع من تشجيع الناس على فهم تاريخهم
هوايات تحب ان تصنع
المربى في المنزل
كميات كبيره من الثمار في اب وايلول
وتشرين الاول ولا يمكن ان تؤكل كلها في
الوقت نفسه كميات التفاح والعليق والبرقوق
التي يمكن ان تاكليها محدوده اذهب الى
بستاني واقطف التفاحه والعليق واخذها الى
المنزل واصنع منها المربى ولدي الكثير من
المربى في المنزل استمتع بصنعه واعطائه
للناس
حياتك شعرتها
الندم ربما او سالت نفسك او حدثت نفسك
لماذا اقدمت على هذا يا جميل
اشياء اقول ربما كان يجب ان افعل كذا او
كذلك
ربما كان يجب ان اكون اقوى في ذلك الموقف
وهكذا
والا لن يتعلق عندما
اتخذت الموقف الصحيح الذي يجب اتخذه نعم
المرء يرتكب اخطاءا كلنا نفعل لكن لا
ينبغي ان تقسو على نفسك
احيانا تنضبين الحياه الى مسارات لم يخطط
لها لكننا نحتاج لاختيار الزاويه المضيئه
وسير نحوها
طريقه
[موسيقى]
مترقبه لقاء شخص اخر مع جانب اخر جديد